nearly a dozen young men are charged
with hazing in the death of a Louisiana
State University freshman Maxwell
groover died last month after becoming
highly intoxicated at a fraternity
pledge event 10 current and former LSU
students are accused of forcing forcing
this 18 year old to heavily drink
groover is at least a second student to
die this year after a hazing incident
involving alcohol in February you may
remember Penn State student Timothy
Piazza died Omar Villafranca is on LSU's
campus in Baton Rouge
Omar good morning good morning all 10
suspects were members of the Phi Delta
Theta fraternity here at LSU but the
National Organization has since
terminated their membership now
witnesses say groover was targeted
because he was often late to events and
they forced him to drink because he had
trouble reciting the Greek alphabet
during pledging it took less than 5
hours for all 10 current and former LSU
students to surrender to campus police
on Wednesday the men were arrested and
brought to the local prison all are
charged with one misdemeanor count of
hazing 19-year old Matthew nock Han is
also charged with a felony count of
negligent homicide
according to the affidavit he was the
most aggressive during the alleged
hazing incident his bail was set at
$10,000 nine of the suspects were
released on bond in less than 24 hours I
don't think he's gonna be pleading
guilty at this point Franz Beauregard is
an attorney for Shawn Penniston I don't
know what happened in that fraternity
house I have my clients version of the
story I'm looking forward to seeing
everyone else's version of the story
we're gonna do it in a court of law an
arrest warrant shows pledges received a
text message on September 13th ordering
them to Bible study at 10 p.m. at the
chapter house once their pledges were
quizzed about the fraternities history
if they answered a question incorrectly
they were forced to drink 190-proof
alcohol around midnight
witnesses say groover was highly
intoxicated and left on a couch nine
hours later he was found with a weak
pulse fraternity members took him to the
hospital where he was pronounced dead an
autopsy revealed groovers blood-alcohol
level will
point four nine five percent at the time
of his death more than six times the
legal driving limit and nearly two times
what's considered to be a
life-threatening level of alcohol
Justin Franklin shared a suite with
Gruber in a dorm on campus if you're
supposed to be a club full of friends
and people who have life lasting
relationships what his life have to end
so early if convicted of hazing the
suspects could get 30 days in jail and
also expelled from LSU now if convicted
nach Han could get five years in prison
for that negligent homicide charge the
district attorney does plan to take over
in the investigation and says more
charges could be filed Charlie thanks
Omar